good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
and i am proud to welcome you to our
final edition
of our
2021-2022 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar series this lecture
series has been supported by uva's
integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain
institute the college of arts and
sciences the school of data science and
through a grants from the national
institutes of general medical sciences
this year's theme has been ethical
challenges of artificial intelligence
and biomedicine where we have enjoyed
presentations on fridays from leading
thinkers about the promise opportunities
and the hurdles associated with ai
applications in the biomedical sciences
selected participants in our biomedical
data science innovation lab program have
been able to leverage these
presentations as vital material for our
culminating in-person grant project
development workshop to be held here
next month in charlottesville virginia i
am delighted to welcome our speaker
today and the final speaker of our
series dr brian wright from the school
of data science here at the university
of virginia
dr wright is one of our
2021-2022 biomedical data science
innovation lab mentors and he serves
currently as an assistant professor and
the director of undergraduate programs
at the university of virginia's school
of data science he holds degrees from
the university of tennessee including a
phd in higher education and higher
education administration and an mpa in
public administration and a bachelor of
science in economics prior to joining
the university of virginia in 2019
dr wright developed the masters of data
science program at george washington
university where he taught for several
years and while at george washington he
founded their data science institute and
helped to develop the creation of a
joint phd in education and in data
science
dr wright began his career with the
department of defense as a management
consultant and researcher with a focus
on enterprise resource planning and
conversation
a conversion excuse me in continuing our
2021-22 biomedical data science seminar
series uh brian's lecture today is
entitled instilling diversity into a
data science undergraduate curriculum
dr wright will discuss with us the
process of helping to build the very
first data school of data science in the
country and this will include the
necessity of developing an agreed-upon
definition of data science um instilling
diversity into an undergraduate program
and providing opportunities to shape
undergraduate under education and data
science as a field that is inclusive
diverse and uh exciting and
forward-thinking
in his lecture he will also include
specific examples that have proven
effective in other stem-oriented fields
and uh we're really looking forward to
his lecture al as always we are
streaming this lecture live and for
recording by youtube and if you're
watching on youtube thank you so much
for joining us also our specially
selected 2021 biomedical data science
innovation lab participants are
encouraged to submit any questions for
brian by the chat feature in their zoom
sessions and i will synthesize these and
ask them on your behalf during the last
10 minutes or so of the lecture and with
that welcome brian we are really looking
forward to your lecture
great thanks so much for the uh kind
words and introduction jack i will i'll
just jump right into it here uh so uh
this is the title we're going to create
talk about creating a diverse
undergraduate bachelor's of data science
this is me i guess we already did most
of this so i'll just jump
kind of to the next slide here i want to
foreground this with i don't assume to
have all of the answers it's a very
complicated space you know there's lots
of solutions you know so sometimes the
best way to prove that they work is to
actually
implement them and so we're going to
look through some research that has done
just that but i'm going to hit some key
highlights that i think are pretty
important and the context behind this
which i think is
important to have is that we are
actually in the process and jack knows
this very well because he's on my
committee that's helping me do this is
that we are in the process of developing
the undergraduate bachelor of science
here uh at the school of data science at
uva so this will be the first
undergraduate
full degree
inside the school so we have kind of a
nice opportunity to think about exactly
what we wanted to look like and to
instill some of these best practices
that we know from research can really
help in terms of just getting diversity
and keeping that diversity
in the school in forms of retention so
uh i got about six points to cover all
right i'll try and go through some some
of them will be a bit more in depth um
and like i said i don't assume to have
all the answers here um but these are
ones that i have either implemented in
the past or have uh you know kind of
taken a look at through other research
avenues that we know to that that we
know that work okay so let's jump right
into it so
so the first thing and i i know this has
been covered a lot but like the way that
i think about this what is data science
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna try and
frame it um but what i do want people to
think of it as for this
point of this talk is that it really is
kind of this once in a generation maybe
even more right opportunity so i can
contextualize what that means here at
the school of data science at uva given
we're the first one in the country but
even more broadly than that you don't
get that many opportunities
um
when we think about the life cycle of
academic
endeavors to actually build a new field
right especially a new stem field
so when we think about data science we
can all debate about whether that's
the content of how much ces or stats but
i think really what it represents
especially for the context of this
conversation is just this amazing
opportunity to say to ourselves how can
we build a culture in a field
that you know kind of sets aside some of
the ills that we have with current stem
education we know um in terms of the
ways that people get into it or the
retention rates or the diversity
measures there so we really have this
amazing you know kind of you know once
in a lifetime possibly the opportunity
to do that and uh and so that's the
context for this so i want to think
about it that way as we as we kind of
move through this and i have some
foregrounding slides here i'll just talk
about kind of the rapid growth of data
science you know we
we talked about we're kind of
beginning to define it was largely built
pretty much in the in the in the master
space right so we have this chart here
from the advanced
analytics center there at uh north
carolina state
uh and they just show here that the
rapid you know kind of the incredible
growth of uh data science programs in
the united states you know kind of
beginning around down here in the mid
you know 2010s and then now we're way up
here
you know pushing you know 350 programs
almost all of which
are in um in the graduate space and the
particular side isn't the graduate space
so the next kind of frontier um
for data sciences is largely in the
undergraduate space there are some phd
programs
those have tends to be a bit more
specialized but what we see now in
relation to this trend is that likely
this
type of chart will be duplicated
probably for the 2020s
but in the undergraduate space there are
many many programs at least i talked to
other program directors
uh around the country or other schools
and other associations that we're
involved with and they're all thinking
about
developing undergraduate programs and so
we have kind of this we're at this
unique point here when we think about
how we you know have stem education and
undergraduate as a foundation
of people moving through and getting
phds in these particular fields
increasing diversity to really take
advantage of it because we're on kind of
the front end to this curve so that's
kind of the foreground at least for the
undergraduate space
um
[Music]
all right this is just an another chart
there showing the number of students
that have graduated i think we're
pushing cumulative numbers over 50 000
now in terms of just
graduate
data science degrees that have been
awarded
all right
oh and this is just a fun chart i want
to show this this is a variety of
courses actually in my just kind of it's
kind of a biased sample here but this is
a distribution of majors
in my machine learning undergraduate
course and you can see here and i think
this is you know for the context of this
nice to see that there are neuroscience
we have biomedical engineering but the
point here
is that we have a variety
of uh majors everything from english uh
and
economics have a lot of computer science
here but a lot of students and a lot of
different undergraduate majors really
interested
in data science and these are students
that are declared for the data science
minor here at uva of which we have about
300 and this is just a sample from just
my undergraduate classes about 60
students where they're coming from so
this kind of mirrors this idea that not
only do you know could we see this
potential really large growth but also
that we're going to see
you know a lot of interest from a lot of
variety of different
degrees right and this could be
analogous to a lot of variety of
different types of students
so again kind of a
nice point in time to think about what
is a data science undergraduate degree
and what what do we what are the best
practices that we can create and support
in order to make sure that that's a
healthy stem environment all right
so uh to continue to fork around here
we've seen a lot of growth in stem you
know i think some of this is actually a
bit
underestimated but you know since 1990
to
to 2019 here we've seen it basically
double you know it's about 30 of all the
degrees conferred
in the united states right now right but
we still have some issues with stem in
terms of just diversity generally and we
think about centering on women
here there was a share of stem that grew
over the same period from 32 to 34
over these 10-year period that's not
that's not much growth
and consideration of the total
population of women that have gone to
school over that same period of time
and then here that we see that there's
some
performance measures that are different
between students that are actually in
bachelor's degrees in data science or
district degrees in stem at 44 that
actually make it in to workforce
positions there's probably lots of
reasons for that
but i think a big reason that we might
be concerned relative to this is that
there appears to be a proportion of um
you know skilled technical workforce
that's been totally unchanged right over
the over 10 years
um
and so if we dig a little bit deeper
into this the distribution of women in
bachelor's degrees in stem
is also a bit huge right actually pretty
heavily skewed towards
life sciences or social sciences and the
ones that are probably most analogous
right to data science
are probably these three right so
physical science but especially computer
science
and engineers so we think of the
percentage of distribution of women in
stem fields here and this is all from
2019 pretty low
in terms of computer and mathematical
sciences and then also engineer so we
have again kind of an opportunity here
to do things a bit better try to balance
this out especially in consideration
that women now make up a majority
of the um total enrollments uh in higher
education
we dig a little bit deeper here uh we
see these same problems there seems to
be some you know kind of
misrepresentation of uh blacks hispanics
and american
indians and alaskan natives they make up
about 30 of the total population but
only 20
of the stem workforce right so they're
largely
under
represented and this comes out of that
same national science foundation kind of
report about why the reasons
for this that might occur and that you
know they're they're kind of
driving uh force through this through
this publication here was about the need
to create a better pipeline for stem
workers especially as it relates to
getting them access to bachelor's
degrees or higher education generally
all right
uh so this again i guess
to overemphasize this point this is the
distribution across different
racial
groups here in terms of just
people receiving all right science and
engineering degrees in 2019 you see here
that there's a pretty disproportionate
percentage associated with hispanics as
it relates to associate degrees as
compared to bachelor's degrees and you
can compare that to where we're sitting
for the white population of students
it's also true for
for black and the other minorities that
are here all right
so it seems like there's they're getting
into these associate degree programs
right but that proportion doesn't
necessarily carry over right into the
bachelor's degrees which we know is
linked to kind of the most workforce
success and creates a foundation for all
sorts of other things in terms of just a
healthy society of people coming up and
being able to contribute to the
scientific community all right
all right so uh this is actually in in
spite of a rather significant investment
in stem education from the federal
government
all right so the congressional research
service you know that estimates that the
federal government spends about 3.1
billion just in stem education programs
these aren't stem related grants or
supporting of research that's just stem
education programs and that's adjusted
for inflation between the periods of
2010 and
2020 so
that's a lot that's that's i didn't have
to do that for you that's 31 billion
dollars
over the last decade of investment in
stem education programs a lot of which
was designed to increase
diversity uh and create these pathways
and we've seen from the previous slides
that that have marginal effects at best
so we have to think of ways that maybe
we can improve this all right and
there's just fun facts here the un
estimated at 30 billion
or actually solve the uh global food
crisis all right so that's that's an
important note just in scale of what 30
billion dollars can do you could hire a
half a million new public school
teachers with that money and then um
the last one kind of less fun i guess
you could not that's not enough to buy
twitter so uh sorry elon okay but 30
billion dollars
quite a lot of money all right so let's
talk about ways that we can design
undergraduate programs that that we know
have proven based off research
and um
and uh and and i'll talk about how we're
thinking about implementing that as
we're developing this new undergraduate
program here
at uva so the first place is uh to have
multiple pathways and to minimize
competitive nature of these programs
i know that can sound
antithetical but the idea here is to
give it's basically to be high flex to
provide lots of ways to come into the
program and then let competition occur
once they're in not before all right
doesn't mean that we reduce the rigor or
the quality of these programs we still
want them to be very high but we want to
be able to be flexible to try and get
students in and then once they're in
providing the necessary supports and
then keep that maintain that level of
rigor that we know is necessary for
learning right i'm going to talk there's
a lot to talk about
here but
given the time that we have
i'm going to try and focus on first the
relationships with two-year schools and
then i'll touch some of these other ones
when we think about just multiple
pathways in the relationship with
two-year schools tends to be a really
important one
all right so this is just this is from
the
american association of community
colleges they put out this infographic
here there's to highlight some of the
facts here associated with this you'll
see that the diversity measures
associated with students coming in to
two-year degrees over here it tends to
be a quite a bit higher than we see it's
kind of natural not actually that much
more but
quite a bit uh at least at least um in
terms of just the
number of students there certainly
certainly larger and we all think that
other demographics a first generation
students um that are in community
colleges that's a bit hard to read but
down here this number in particular
that's about 30 percent some of them are
single parents
add those together right so 30 is much
larger than the national average for
first generation students which is
around 20 so there's a significant
portion of first generation students and
minority students that go
into two-year schools right which is uh
makes it an important avenue for us to
understand and create pathways with into
four-year degrees so having
relationships
with two-year schools in order to be
able to encourage diversity is is
significant and there's some some facts
over here on the side
right that among african-american or
black students that graduate with a gpa
of 3.5 or higher 33 percent of them
attend a community college that's a high
number right that's closer to 22
for white or caucasians so we can see
this can really be
uh an important thing to consider when
we're talking about creating pathways
into
into four-year programs
to encourage diversity all right
this is just to give you an idea of the
total number
of two years is from the same
same institution here
and so we can see that over time we've
had kind of steady increases in the
number of enrollments in education
generally for a year we're up here
around 10 million all right but a
significant portion of that
all right maybe close to i think it's 45
something like that is
in two-year programs all right we've
seen actually a pretty big drop in this
over time in covet you know pandemic
didn't make this much better when it's
fluctuations in terms of economic
realities or you know a global pandemic
usually two-year schools are the ones
that suffer the most because the
students that enroll in those are forced
to do other things decide attend from
school besides attend school but we can
see here that it does make up a
significant portion of the total
population of those attending post kind
of post-primary
education
programs all right
all right so relationships with two-year
schools i want to highlight some things
here too about um what i mean by that
all right so really what i'm talking
about is developing at least this is
kind of what the educational research
will tell us is that a lot of what
restricts students from understanding
what they can do well after they're done
with their two-year program is actually
their ability to have access to that
information right to understand that
there are these transfer programs all
right that that they can talk to
counselors they can be admitted into
four-year programs there's direct admits
uh so a lot of that that that
understanding of the world of
possibilities is is encapsulated with
this idea about social capital is that
minority students first generation
students especially don't have the same
amount of social capital that that
students
students that come from um parents that
have
gone through this process or have um
bachelor's degrees right or even higher
they just don't have uh relationships
that allow them to understand what the
potential options are and advantages
right of going from two-year to
four-year
and so
vincent tito uh tinto was the original
framework of this and he associated
social capital with kind of educational
isolation right and he was the one that
created original framework about how
this can lead to to dropout rates and
retention to a nerve um year over year
in four-year degrees so his idea about
essentially that
um dropout is very similar to social
isolation and that is akin to kind of
this lack of social capital that
students have on campus and that can
come in the representation of peers or
faculty members or family members
there's the idea that that is a
significant contributor and there's now
a huge body of research he did this back
in them actually started in the 80s but
a huge body of research to support this
idea about kind of how um
right social capital can make a huge
difference in terms of students having
success across the board all right
there's a bunch of studies that show
that this type of social capital can be
gained through peer and fam and faculty
engagement
all right these are some examples here
all right so this particular article
kind of did a lot of interviews across
23 different institutions all right and
it found that especially in the latino
community there was a significant
difference between
students that successfully navigated
through the community college and then
and on to four-year degrees that had
strong relationships with their adult
males right in their family that did the
same thing or male faculty members that
help them kind of understand what the
pathways were right so there were some
significant differences there that's one
example
right and this is an example from some
work that i did earlier that associated
with this that there was a
a significant difference in terms of
engagement and peer mentorship
as it relates
to social capital for first-generation
students when compared to
non-first-generation students in terms
of their level of success on campus
all right so what we see here and
there's there's lots of like i said
studies that support this is that this
type of
um
this type of designing programs and
starting to understand what what it
means to develop this social capital for
students to facilitate it can really
make a difference in terms of how
students are transitioning or being
successful through this
two year to four-year pipeline all right
this is another one uh that was
especially relevant here that talked
about um you know community college
across california they reviewed 42
community colleges and what they did is
they worked and created recommendations
about how to create programs at
four-year institutions that could
essentially
allow uh students of african-american
descent to gain
to gain more social capital in the forms
of building relationships with existing
institutions in order to be able to
reduce that student equity gap in terms
of their transition out of community
college into four-year institutions
okay
there's a link here i think for the sake
of time i probably won't click on it but
there are lots of transfer success
programs right that are making actually
a pretty huge difference this particular
site has a few of them on there there's
actually several in virginia they're
from george nation virginia tech and vcu
uva has has ones as well especially as
it relates to its uh
to the college of wise
um and so the idea is that a lot of
these these transfer programs um are
kind of giving boots on the ground going
out to the community colleges and
talking about
um
how students can transfer the pipelines
the requirements for that and then even
going further to match them with peer
mentors that have done that process
right that are successfully transferred
and are doing well in the academic
environment in that college and that
that can make huge differences that will
actually dive a little bit more into
that but not just giving them a flyer
and saying hey these are the
opportunities but actually allowing them
to connect with people that have
successfully done it
and really kind of rely on them to to
provide advice
can make a big difference
okay
other ways that we talk about kind of um
you know multiple pathways in and out of
degree that's one that you know from
from two-year schools in particular is
an important one when we think about
kind of injecting diversity but also
inside the program the way that we've
designed it is that we do have a minor
which is essentially the first four
classes that students would take in the
major so that if they're not sure that
they want to do a data science
major they can start with a minor and
then they can build credits see if it's
a right fit for them and if it is then
they can jump into the program it turns
out that they come into the data science
minor or date science major
and it is not right for them
all right one thing that they can do is
they can leave with a credential and get
the minor right so after the first year
if they just think hey this isn't right
for me
uh then they they don't lose those
credits so to speak right they can
off-ramp out of the major and still
receive the minor then move on to
something maybe that that might be more
you know connected to their personal
interests the other thing that we're
making sure to do is that we're
connecting it with the other liberal
arts requirements on campus so again
that these students aren't losing
credits as they go through our program
that they can take these credits if they
decide to stay or even double major is
is a big thing
um that they won't lose those credits
there's a big uh there's a lot of
information and
and studies relative to credit
accumulation and student success so both
of these are related to making sure that
students don't fall behind if they
happen to change their plans while on
grounds um and they can still you know
accumulate credits at a that would be a
um
a uh appropriate rate for them to
graduate within four years all right
we're also going to have multiple
application periods this is kind of akin
to what we just talked about with on and
off
we are going to allow for one time first
admissions just direct admit they'll
apply to uva if you get into uva
then you can say that hey i'd like to be
a data science major and then you'd
start that all right after your first
year we're going to have a much larger
admissions period after that first year
that's going to typically most students
will come in come on grounds start to
take some prerequisites and then apply
over the summer and then the transfer
just like i just like i talked about
either internal or external the
important part of that is to develop
those relationships with the two-year
schools and then match the courses so
they can transfer over as many credits
as possible
and then we will have plus one programs
so
eventually once the master's program
kind of changes a little bit so we will
allow students to go through the
undergraduate and then just get one year
masters all right
so students can envision themselves
moving through even into graduate school
is an important precedent to student
success
okay
incentives okay so
i have three three things to talk about
here incentives is broadly defined but
these are incentives really for us as
program managers to make sure that we're
tracking
uh
you know tracking certain elements of
the diversity of our student pool that
we're hitting certain targets so we have
to build these things in right from the
beginning otherwise
kind of trying to inject them into the
culture later can be can be quite
difficult
so incentives mean what are the
incentives for us to make sure that
we're doing this on a regular basis
throughout the life of this program and
not just thinking about it kind of ad
hoc so one way that we can do that and
again jack is familiar with these
because he's been very involved in this
but
is to build in requirements for
diversity into the actual evaluation of
the program that we will send to the
state regulating body so we just
foreground it up front and say hey that
we're you know we want to match the
diversity of the populations here at uva
we say that because
that is the population which we are
restricted to we hope to influence that
to make it more diverse
as the stool starts to come up and
becomes more attractive but
we are constrained to the students that
are here so we want to make sure to
match or exceed the kind of existing
demographics
at uva and here we have hugs is defined
as historically underrepresented groups
we have a pretty broad definition of
what that means but we want that six
year graduation rate to be at 95 percent
and then uh down here at the bottom two
is this last one all right then i've
just highlighted a few of these there
and these are on all the metrics that
we're using these are kind of the ones
that we're building into the actual
governing documents that we're sending
to the state but i think it's important
to put these in here just to make sure
that
we get it right right from the beginning
okay
so robust measures for student success
this includes not just uh how are they
doing in terms of just you know kind of
wrote gpa but also
matching it to learning outcomes and
engagement so
engagement can play a huge factor and we
know through
through you know probably pushing 30
years of research now that engagement is
directly related to
you know self-efficacy and student
performance and even post-graduate
you know student success in the broadest
sense so engagement is really about how
involved they are with the university
community which is again linked to
tinto's model associated with dropout
rates that the higher they are engaged
with the university the better they do
across the board on all sorts of
different things so it's important for
us
to think about when we're measuring
student success to not just think about
it as how many students are passing
similar to what we just showed on the
previous slide but to be kind of
all-encompassing about that all right
so there's lots of research here
that kind of supports that to show that
there's you know a strong correlation
between um you know thinking about
student engagement and success very
broadly this one measure here is kind of
a holistic measurement approach that
includes not only gpa or credit
accumulation but also the level of
engagement right so the more you measure
a thing especially as they found in this
particular article here is that the
students there was a pretty big
differential between students that
showed high levels of engagement in
terms of self-efficacy and self-esteem
and that related directly towards higher
student performance so they're measuring
these two things
continuously all right
and this is just a this is a meta study
that tried to look and um and just to
quantify a bit better based off all the
years of research we put into this you
know is this actually true that
engagement can lead to achievement they
went across uh 70 studies here you know
200 000 participants and they found that
there were pretty strong connections
between achievement and high levels of
engagement
right
across all of these studies
so we know this to be true and so it's
important when you think about designing
the program is that we think about
student success as broadly as possible
all right
so uh we also need systematic processes
for student feedback all right so we
need to engage students in their own
learning and provide avenues for them to
provide you know honest feedback
especially as we're just starting to
build this
um we want to understand what works and
what does it you know and it actually
increases engagement right so akin to
what i just talked about in the previous
slide anything that we could do to
further engage students in their own
learning increases their own
self-confidence right and it helps to
retain minority and first generation
students all right
all right the next point here is that
students really need to see themselves
in the degree all right so this what i
mean by that is that it's important for
black students to see black professors
for hispanic students to see hispanic
professors for women to see themselves
in the professors that are looking back
at them all right and it's just not it's
not just professors
it's teaching assistants or alumni
speakers or even certain case studies
right that we use in class right and
another thing that this could manifest
in is upper level students
participating in the early career of the
more junior students right so get
students involved with students and
thinking about how to match them up in
terms of
race and ethnic and background matching
we know can make a significant
difference in
student performance in particular
retention right i want to highlight this
one because i've got some additional
points that i'm going to talk about you
know later in the presentation about how
this one in particular works all right
uh so here all right this is just some
research that shows this all right um in
terms of just seeing themselves in the
degree
all right this study here was a greater
faculty diversity it led to significant
increases
in the um outcomes of students
especially as they're related to
african-american students
in terms of them just matching and
seeing themselves
in the degree all right so this was one
that was done at a higher at higher
education institutions it seemed like it
was a very good predictor of gpa and
overall graduation if students
were matched up with uh race matched
teachers and mentors
all right
similar study uh it just focused on this
is through k-12 right focused on the
impacts of
particular um
race-based matching in the k-12 system
and it found that overall that there
were some maybe not as strong
correlations as we saw in the previous
study but that scores on standardized
tests for those students that were race
and ethnic matched were significantly
higher alright and they had better
behavioral outcomes associated with
in classroom
performance
so both at higher education at the
higher education level when we think
about you know post
post secondary and in k through 12 it
seems to be significant difference here
in uh in these two studies as it relates
to just the benefits of this race
matching all right
so the next thing that we think about
here is um student support services so
we've talked about a number of points
here that are important again to kind of
increase diversity and retain diversity
students inside your program and having
once they're here on campus providing
support services is going to be a
critical one now this this particular
point there's a lot there's a lot to
cover here
but i'm going to try and isolate it down
um to specifically peer mentoring all
right so i've talked about this idea
of building social capital and we know
that one of the best ways to do that as
we've already seen in some of the
research examples is to get students in
front of students that have the same
lived experience
so this one here this example is is is
really
pretty impressive you know so this first
year this is a chemistry laboratory that
has problems with retention year over
year in terms of dropping out but they
went to kind of a model that included
peer mentors in a cohort program and
they were able to increase student
retention by 20
year after year just by implementing
this kind of simple peer mentoring
program they even highlight here the
program is uncomplicated and requires
just modest resources right and
significantly increased stem retention
in this particular program
all right here's another example for
peer mentoring and social capital gain
all right so this was a a um
a study that focused on
a hispanic serving institution all right
where they they looked at about
uh 450 students and they were matched
with mentors over three years and then
they analyzed that data and they found
that the mentees reported
increased university integration and
post-testing significantly greater than
the non-mentor students and so this is
akin to what we talked about earlier
about engagement and how they can make a
huge difference and where students are
engaged and they're integrated into the
community they're much less likely
to drop out and stay and complete their
degree and this type of peer mentoring
can make a huge significant difference
in that um
as this study kind of articulates
especially with this minority population
this is the last one here and this is
kind of a well-known
well-known study of the university of
texas el paso
i'm sorry that this rendered kind of
badly but i'll hit you through the
highlights here we can see at the very
bottom here that um what happened is
that the they were they went from kind
of they had a very significant problem
with retention year after year
especially from first to second year
which is very common all right so they
went to a more community based model
right which included
peer mentors of older
uh students inside the program right
coming and speaking with new students
and developing those relationships
uh over time
right so this is a population university
that had over 80 percent
was hispanic
and if we just go all the way down to
the bottom they did some other things
too about applying kind of active
learning concepts and immersing them
into research but peer mentorship was
one of the things that they developed in
the community
and let me just highlight this down here
and again i'm sorry it's a little hard
to read
but they saw that their retention rates
by implementing these series of programs
nearly doubled from 43 to 80
um and then the average time for
graduation decreased by almost two years
that that is a that is an amazing uh
improvement
um and it this is a holistic change they
did a lot of things here so it wasn't
just peer mentoring but a big key of it
was getting those students in front of
other students and trying to help them
develop those relationships and find be
integrated and supported into the campus
and then
it really had just a dramatic impact as
we can see
in terms of retaining those students
all right
uh students life support okay so we
actually flip that around but anyway
these are the final things here
we need we do need to think about not
just kind of this peer mentor i just
want to hit some more of these
highlights you know that there are real
financial concerns and so we're thinking
about private partnerships in the firms
of scholarships and then also kind of
reduce tuition rates inside the school
and then you know academic
we really do need to get them tutoring
and i had some success in the past in
terms of developing interest networks
around specific topics and that might be
you know neuroscience or biomedical
medicine whatever that might be
to get those students together and then
start just talking about those concepts
through shared through shared interests
one that has a tendency to work really
well as social good and and sports
actually when you think about the
specific instances that might occur in
data science programs
okay
the last one here is uh is is about
pedagogy all right so we've kind of gone
through um you know the opportunities
that we have in data science where we're
at for that right we've gone through how
to develop these two-year relationships
and some techniques associated with how
we can support these students but it's
also important that we think about just
not you know the environment
um to get them here and then all of the
support services but also what happens
inside the classroom so there's a lot of
research that associates active based
learning to improve retention
and minority especially in minority and
first generation students right this is
an example here right that talked about
a program associated with
underrepresented minority students
that proved to show
significant increases
in terms of their
ability to uh just retain in the course
and then also to um
perform as compared to when they did not
implement this active based program
there's about 250 students in this
particular one and it supports as it
says on the bottom there a significant
amount of research that uh inclusive um
that active activity-based
pedagogy really does help with inclusive
teaching
and pathways for a diverse standard
workforce all right
this one should be
behind the one before it but i can just
tell you that it's the same as this
particular one here i just wanted to
highlight this again because one of the
things that they did and again in this
well-known study at the university of
texas el paso is that they
they immersed students into research
projects right from the beginning so
they were problem-based
problem-based
labs and they were supported with
faculty and they actually
worked them through a research process
as one of the first things they did when
they got on campus so as compared to
maybe just kind of these are the
electives you have to take your first
year that every student takes they
immerse these students into a
community-based learning environment and
then had them in there doing training uh
very hands-on applied active learning
based methods doing
problem-based problem-based learning and
research experiences right in their
first year and that again contributed to
this significant difference
in um
in retention year after year almost
doubling
okay
so uh active learning does well there it
is so i put it up kind of without it all
right this is duplication and just to
emphasize this so we're trying to do
some things here at the school we
submitted a lab to the presidents and
provost fund for data science active
learning lab
as one of the project goals here we
wanted to kind of encourage the creation
of cultural norms as it relates to how
data science is taught especially in the
undergraduate space right the proven
benefit
um to improve outcomes for
underrepresented groups
and first generation students and the
idea is that we want to take this
content you know about how we can create
these kind of activity-based labs and
learning structure and just make it free
and open right to encourage other data
science undergraduate programs
to take these things
and implement them all right so if we
know that they work um not only they
work for minority and first generation
and underrepresented groups they work
for everybody right so student
performances in terms of learning
outcomes uh
appear to be clearly linked to this type
of pedagogical approach but especially
as it relates to these groups of
students that we're thinking about
so
this is one of the ways that we're
trying to develop this kind of as a
cultural norm in the school and then
hope it occur encourage this type of
activity outside the walls of uva
we also have a collaboratory for the
advancement
of education and data science it's
called kids all right and so the goal
here is to really you know facilitate an
opportunity for uva faculty and students
to work together
right engage not only in data but also
partner with the schools as well and so
this is related to all the things that
we talked about you know trying to get
students involved in research
partnerships as much as we can and we're
also focusing on projects that kind of
directly related to some of these goals
and then over the summer as an instance
i have
i have three undergraduate students that
are going to help me on these projects
that we're doing as part of the
collaboratory and we're really just
getting started so we're hoping to have
you know kind of a robust portfolio of
projects that are in the education space
that we can engage students in that will
not only increase you know their
engagement just on campus but also that
the outcomes of these particular uh
research projects could benefit the
field
at large given the time constraints i
won't get into the details of the two of
those but
uh also this is our view of data science
uh i'm happy to ask questions about this
um but we see we see it as very balanced
across these four pieces
um and this is the way that we're
designing the undergraduate programs
analytics is is typically what people
think of when you think of data science
it's machine learning
statistics designs associated with
communication
of data science tools and actually the
designing of kind of human centered
design products systems is everything we
need to be able to do the
to do the data sciences everything from
coding to high performance computing to
cloud-based systems and then value is
kind of what we think about is the
ethical and policy elements associated
with data science and how we use these
algorithms ethically and think about the
human impact and
practice as you might suspect is how we
put it all together so this is how we're
designing the programs as a whole and
then this is kind of what the actual
program in the undergraduate looks like
i'm happy to ask more questions about
that but i'm trying to leave it at a
high level the concentrations
will be in each one of those domain
areas which is another i think unique
feature so students can see themselves
if they have a tendency to be less
computational or less computer science
oriented that we have design and ethical
elements associated with this field so
we're trying to creep it as broad as
possible which is another tenement we
think that would lead to increased
diversity of the students coming into
the undergraduate program
so with that that's it thanks
ryan thank you so much um
obviously we're
you're leading the the the uh effort
here at uva to build these curriculums
and frankly i this is just the first i'm
sure we're going to see these popping up
all across the country
and recruiting diversity into them is
vitally important and you touched on a
number of different areas
i'm curious about the
possible recruitment opportunities that
may also exist maybe you didn't touch on
for example reaching out to um
historically black colleges and
universities to see if
there's interested in kind of
cross-pollinating students or
any activities like that i'm curious if
you could comment on that also about um
are there any organizations such as the
women in data science organization that
possibly might be a a um
a way for
greater um
i don't know just for for women to see
data science as a possible career path
for them
not maybe they're not quite used to it
but maybe there's a way through
organizations such as that to kind of
get the word out um
and also at the level of high school um
you know if you can catch people before
they decide on where their college
trajectory is maybe there's a way to get
more people there these are just a
couple different things that i wanted to
see if you had some comments on
yeah yeah absolutely so start at the top
that hbcus is a great you know i think
we've done that we did that at gw a good
bit actually we partnered with them we
had research symposiums and we made sure
to have
you know kind of representation from
these you know historic um you know
black minority institutions and that
that helped out a lot right and i think
we all learned from each other and i
think there's opportunities to continue
to do that through kind of dedicated
programming whether that comes in the
form of summer research programs or
whether we even think about creating
pathways for those types of students if
they if they wanted to transfer into our
program
i think that's an important thing to
consider um
and so yeah so at the k through 12. well
let me start with the um kind of women's
and data science actually i'm fairly
lucky here at uva so they're pretty
active kind of women in stem and latino
and stem club groups but there's also
these national groups as well
and we have a conference here as you
know to support women in data science
every year and you know in thinking
about these things that you know it's i
think we're actually
got a pretty good head start on kind of
creating these cultural norms because of
all this activity in the field related
to
getting more diverse voices in it you
know it's a nice time to be starting a
program like this because so you get so
much support for this type of ideal
and a lot of that's already taking place
so some of this you know outside of the
actual creation of this undergraduate
degree i think when you think about
you know where it sits in the larger
landscape it's just a matter of making
sure to engage in those
and do it purposely i think we're doing
a pretty good job here hosting a
conference every year relative to women
in data science but there's always
certainly things you can do more
in the k-12 area we've actually started
an adam donaldson um adam
yeah has been working with um
working with the state of virginia to
develop kind of programming in the k-12
space i think that's like the i mean if
not the current you know co-frontier
with undergraduate
we certainly are getting a lot of
requests about how we can inject data
science
into that and that would help us out
tremendously because i mean that what
we're the reason we have a three-year
degree and not a four-year degree is
we're worried that students are going to
come
to campus not really know what data
science is
and so we're we're trying to give them a
year to understand that and that's why
they have to take a couple of data
science courses their first year
but over time you know if we can
evolve the landscape of data science
education or computer science and you
know computational
computational methods in the k-12 system
that would actually allow us to have a
much you know maybe even get a year back
right we'd have a larger amount of space
bring in students earlier and then push
the curriculum even further
and so i know that um initiatives are
active in several states about that and
i think they're piloting a program
uh next year that will focus on just
kind of data science applied to to
finance very very high at a high level
to give students in the k-12 experience
not just in the you know not just in
not just in data science broadly but
apply it to an area with which they
might be interested and there's a lot of
nonprofit organizations there's one in
new york that's pretty well known that's
doing that same thing
and offering kind of uh going around and
offering high schools and community
colleges right where high school
students can go and take classes
applied data analytics uh data sports
analytics courses where they can get
kind of minority students or
underrepresented students kind of
excited about these applications through
the domain of sports which seems to be
working pretty well
yeah that's great
it's uh yeah
which kind of brings me to in measuring
post-graduate job success so we've
provided this education and
we have
women and minority data scientists are
charging out into the workforce
do are we prepared to
measure their job success and uh one of
our participants asked what is the
optimal or equitable representation in
your opinion of the minority groups in
the data science workforce that we
should try strive to achieve
we wanted to mirror the general
population of them in the u.s right so
from an economic standpoint we can think
about students think about a population
of those that are actively seeking work
we know what the demographics of that
are
and there's no reason that stem careers
shouldn't mirror that i mean i many of
the opportunities especially as it
relates to generational wealth and
success come through stem education we
know there's research that supports that
idea
and so
for us to have disproportionate um you
know minority groups that are working in
that is is is a concern across the board
right even for the future what we think
about kind of economic
you know benefits of those groups so i i
think that's that should be the minimum
goal um and then you know i think we
should think about you know what our
real aspirations are to try and to try
and excel that i mean part part of the
problem is that we we're doing fairly
well when you think about just
um you know diversity overall in terms
of in terms of people going into either
two or four-year degrees
but retention is still such a huge
problem and we still lose like on
average 30 of all college students drop
out
every year right and it's higher for
minority students and first generation
students you know it's like closer to of
that population you know they make up an
unbalanced percentage of it a higher
percentage
you know in a 10 million students a year
you know that's that's this 300 000
students that are either withdrawing or
going to part-time or removing
out of uh out of the education system so
you know i think that that's a big
problem so we need to fix that so why a
lot of this talk was focused on not just
identifying and getting in the pipeline
but how do we support them appropriately
to increase and make sure that they
persist
so i think that that's the first step in
trying to try and balance that out
and i you know we think about post
graduation success there are some there
are some some programs that do very well
with this um and they keep track of
their graduates over over more than like
a 10-year period you know the data
science field i think is
is fairly i mean even though it's
well it's just young right so it's only
been around for really you know in a
very robust way you know probably less
than like six or seven years
but i think we need to start thinking
about it's a good point
about what it means to be successful
after
graduation and then what does it mean to
be your generationally successful
especially for first generation students
you know or their or their children then
moving on and having college success you
know there's an important economic
indicator of upward mobility this kind
of generational social capital that gets
passed down
from graduates to graduates so hopefully
we can kind of think about that but it's
a good point
brian are there any other
kind of lessons learned about what does
not work
in promoting diversity
yeah i so that's a it's a good point
this is all about what does work i
i think
you know i
i think being passive doesn't work i'll
just say that i think that you really
have to be
aggressive and go out and and try and
recruit these students
i think a lot of ways we've set up
scholarships
uh when i was at gw we had some
scholarships that were available but the
bad part about it is they actually ended
up using all the money and that's
because students weren't even aware that
it was there
right so you really you really gotta get
you know you gotta get out your shoes
and hit the street i mean develop these
relationships with the two-year schools
like go into high schools and let people
know the availability you have to rely
on your institutions for some of this
but i think you know the other thing
that is important is to experiment right
i mean a lot of the studies that we
showed here they made kind of dramatic
changes and then tracked and saw what
work there's a lot more studies that
that probably don't get published where
they try things and and didn't work
either but i think it's important to
have kind of an experimental
you know approach to this to see what
works but i think the most important
thing is to just not not be passive you
know we we had a really nice program at
gw when i was there that was funded
through the nsf one of the examples of
maybe something that did work as
compared to the billions that didn't
where we would any student that went
through um
community college there northern
virginia community college and got an it
degree
got admitted um automatically
and their tuition was paid for to come
into the gw
information technology bachelors
and if they got through that program
then i we would pay for their masters in
data science so that we could go to the
northern virginia community college and
say
if you make it through this your gpa is
3.0 make it through this program you get
into the bachelor's one we'll pay for
that and if you make it through that
then we'll pay for your master's program
um and that was great we had a ton of
success recruiting students to go
through that pipeline and that was all
supported through uh
through nsf but we couldn't just put it
up on a website
we had to go out there and actively
recruit and it's hard i mean that
students are afraid to go through these
things they're very they're afraid of um
afraid of failure you know it's high
risk
and they have they have
to be honest i think that that a lot of
people uh come from environments where
you know it might actually not even be
encouraged right to pursue this type of
thing
and so there's there's a lot of hurdles
there to get over but i do think that
getting out there and making meaningful
relationships a lot of what we talked
about in terms of developing kind of
that social capital is critical it just
doesn't work
unless you're out there and kind of
build those pathways and with purpose
are there any in kind of i guess it's
almost like an intangible but maybe it's
measurable are there any examples of
where
increased diversity of the technical
workforce on any particular problem in
data science ai machine learning where
increased diversity has reduced biases
that are present in ai and data set
algorithm development or a data
collection or the presentation of
results from ai you know machine
learning
algorithms i know that seems a little
nebulous but i'm just kind of curious if
there's if there's an actual
payoff in terms of the robustness the
reliability and the suitability of kind
of the answers that we're getting from
ai technologies based on diversity i
don't have any studies that i can point
to that quantifiably say yes but um i
have had you know a lot of conversations
and and uh people may be familiar with
this name with kathy o'neil
and and she talks about kind of
implementing these you know kind of
ethical frameworks and um
she wrote a really well a well-known
book called
weapons of mass destruction
but you know that that kind of idea like
to inject that actually comes typically
from kind of a social science background
the idea is up front is to think about
the human element associated with how
the model
will be implemented or how can it go
wrong or what are the things we can
control and not control
and that type of like quasi-experimental
design like on the front end has a
tendency to come from
social science backgrounds and those as
we saw in some of these slides ahead
especially as it relates to women habits
have a tendency to be much more diverse
so i mean it might be a leap of faith
right to suggest
that that is true but i mean if you kind
of walk that line of logic back
we know that you know having a having a
thoughtful you know putting the science
back in data science if you will you
know kind of this you know approach to
foregrounding the problems and then
using some of these ethical frameworks
that are already there is something that
is probably much more
um i would say normative right in some
of the
less harder sciences and um
so kind of the more human centered um
social sciences which have a tendency to
be more diverse so the answer to the
question could be yes yeah uh nicole um
suggests that scott page has written a
bunch about the quote-unquote diversity
bonus and how one might quantify it so
for anybody who's interested that might
be a place to place to look um
any parting comments for us brian
uh
thanks for your time you know if you
want to follow up or have questions
about any of these things i you know i i
love talking about it so i'd be happy to
dig in deeper and um
you know just just reach out but that's
it he will be um he is one of our
mentors um for those of you who are
taking part in our innovation lab next
month uh brian is one of our mentors so
you'll get a lot of chance to interact
with him and ask him a lot of questions
and have some hopefully really deep
conversations about how to boost
diversity and equity um in data science
and how we can
kind of think about ways to make that
pay off uh brian thank you so much for a
really great um discussion about how we
can infuse diversity into undergraduate
data science education such an important
topic um again i hope everybody will
reach out to him so thank you so very
much
everyone this concludes our series of
the data science uh biomedical data
science seminar series and i want to
thank all of you who've joined us each
week i want to thank all of our speakers
who've done such a fantastic job
everybody can find their talks on
youtube and hopefully you will watch
them again you'll share them you'll use
them as foundational content for our
innovation lab next next month for those
of you who are watching on youtube i
hope this is an important resource for
you it's always a joy when people
approach me kind of randomly and say how
much they've enjoyed watching the
seminar series and how much they get out
of these videos so thank you so very
much um and i certainly would be remiss
if i did not say thank you to gina
kamdar and to hannah reichel who have
made a just they just make this run like
like a swiss watch it's really fantastic
to have them um helping me every day uh
and so for those of you um who are
taking part in our innovation lab next
month we really look forward to seeing
you uh we are so excited to do this in
person i cannot tell you um in the
meantime everyone have a great weekend
have a great summer we'll be starting
our innovation lab or sorry a biomedical
data science seminar series once again
in the fall term the topic of which will
be to be determined but uh watch this
space and uh we hope to be able to come
up with a number of other fantastic
speakers uh to present to you so thank
you everyone